welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the
first look trailer footage of the one
division spin-off Agatha darkhold
Diaries formerly titled Agatha coven of
chaos and before that Agatha House of
Harkness and yeah I hope the title of
the series just keeps changing every
weekly episode until we get to Agatha
all along this show is slated to drop in
2024 Halloween according to Patty Leone
and with the release of the wav Vision
steelbook they included this Agatha
promo with a ton of footage and missable
details in Clues pointing to what this
series will be many of you first found
this Channel with my crazy breakdowns of
w division so of course we're going to
be all over this spin-off and you know
I've already lit my black candle for
mephisto's inevitable arrival will I
find misto in this trailer no I don't
think so because I've already found him
you fools thank you to boxu for
sponsoring this video more on their
tasty offerings later okay this promo
begins with Katherine Han recalling how
wav Vision brought back the classic TV
ritual staying home to watch an episode
of TV with your family and friends on
Friday nights classic TGIF Vibes and
then things shift into the Agatha Series
so the promo takes us back to the W
division finale where AGA tells the
Scarlet Witch Wanda before Wanda traps
her in that mental sitcom hex this you
have no idea what you've
unleashed you're going to need me now
when we Revisited this line it kind of
seemed like AA was talking about the
Scarlet wit is the villain in the
upcoming Multiverse of Madness but no no
no no my friends there's something else
that was Unleashed perhaps a flood of
chaos sorcery throughout the Marvel
Universe reactivating every possible
witch that Agatha Harkness had snuffed
out actually last week we saw a deleted
scene for the first time ever that
showed Agatha still in that hex flirting
with the
[Music]
EMT ma'am are you
injured no I'm not handsome but could
always use some mouth to
mouth by the way there was another
deleted scene in which Randall Park is
Jimmy woo would have confirmed Evan
peters's actor Ralph boner as the person
in federal witness protection that he
was looking for a longtime history that
the show up until that point never
answered let's keep an eye out for our
missing witness we still need him to
testify should be easier to spot now
that everything's back to
[Music]
normal oh yeah baby come
on
now Evan Peters is not currently
expected to appear in this Agatha series
but we are left with the question of
what pre Westview FBI case Jimmy wo
needed Ralph boner to testify for and
since Agatha took Ralph as an early
captive as she intruded on Wanda's hex
and now kind of ties her into that whole
Law and Order subplot Vibe it kind of
seems like she will be stuck in a legal
procedural detective show genre at first
in this series it's going to feel like
Law and Order or Law and Order SVU or
any of the other million law and Ord ERS
now in this promo there is a neon sign
that it looks like it's in a clairvoyant
dwelling psychic past present future
this could be Lilia caldero Patty Leone
Broadway Legend is joining this cast as
Lilia caldero a 450 year-old Sicilian
witch with divination Powers who is a
member of Agatha's coven Lilia first
appeared in Marvel Premiere number 12 in
1973 seeking the book of kostro you
remember that from the first Doctor
Strange film she was looking for this
book after Baron MTO took it from her
after Romancing her and she's wanted
Revenge so she works with Dr strange
teaming up with him against MTO but she
dies in the process now Lilia resurrects
later on in Doctor Strange torser
Supreme number 8 1989 and she plays a
new role in 2007's Mystic Arcana Scarlet
Witch number one she wears the serpent
Crown she leads her own coven Lilia can
make herself appear younger and she
claims to have predicted the emergence
of a young Wanda maximoff's sorceress
powers in this series also part of the
coven will be Aubrey Plaza as the witch
Rio the doll a green witch and ex-lover
of Agatha supposedly she's an original
character whose surname could come from
from Contessa Vera vial from the Iron
Fist Immortal Comics SNL's sasher zamita
is playing Jennifer kale who is a
sorceress and throughout the Marvel
Comics she's been a longtime figure who
first appeared in Man thing comics from
1972 and she's appeared in titles like
xforce midnight Suns often a lot of
horror comics and most recently the
current 2023 Scarlet Witch run by Steve
Orlando alian is playing yet another
witch in this coven named Alice and
returning from W division are many of
the people we knew from westf debor Joe
rup as Sharon Davis aka Mrs Hart Emma
Coffield Ford Sarah Proctor AKA doy
Jones David pton as John Collins AKA
herb David langle as Sarah's husband
Harold Proctor AKA Phil Jones as St Ali
as avalash Tandon AKA norm and Amos
Glick as the pizza delivery man AKA
Dennis now in the behind the scenes
footage we see Jack schaer in this
kitchen set that I thought might have
been Agatha's kitchen from W division
episode 7 but that wallpaper is
different in this home there are some
animal prints framed on the wall and I
like how shaer seems to be wearing a
sweatshirt with what looks like a tarot
card design maybe the reader maybe the
world it's kind of kind of hard to tell
one interesting setup shows Agatha in a
morg with a corpse on a gurnie with a
tag on the toe Agatha is wearing her
initial nosy neighbor 1961 outfit from
the very first episode of w division
according to scooper can we get some
toast so take it with a grain of salt
they are claiming that this is part of a
detective storyline as Agatha teams up
with a fellow detective who in this hex
spell sees as special agent roval who
tells Agatha that there are two Jane
Do's on this case and the first Corpse's
toe tag reads W Maxim and then a new
name will appear above Wanda's a
heartness it's kind of hard to tell if
that's true from this shot though I
first thought this corpse was male but
this whole idea of witch corpses
definitely takes us back to The Wizard
of Oz and those feet sticking out from
under Dorothy Gail's house the corpse of
the Wicked Witch of the East which
totally came up in W to Vision episode 9
when Agatha's empty boots stuck out from
under the throne C into the house and
I'm not just pulling this out my ass
this time folks the wizard of O
absolutely a reference point notice that
clapboard the production title was my
pretty now what's weird though is later
later in the trailer Agatha wears 80s
era clothes in this morg location
looking like herself from W division
episode 5 that was a growing pains era
and then yet another shot with Agatha in
her Slimmer purple sweater that she wore
in the Modern Family episode of episode
7 and then again back in her 80s attire
when she rest her hands on one of those
morg metal sinks so it kind of seems
like in this morg location Agatha will
be flashing through several sitcom eras
from when she was under Wanda's hex and
this could be the moment she finally
snaps out of that hex that Wanda left
her under at the end of that series it
might be the sight of her own body maybe
Agatha begins a series as a kind of
deceased Spirit ghost try to make it
back into the living realm yeah
entanglement is a big component of what
makes the Marvels fun and you can keep
that fun going by entangling snacking
and surprise with bxu boxu is a premium
Japanese snack box that works with
family businesses all over Japan to
deliver a new theme of authentic
Japanese snacks every month and honestly
it makes a great gift fun snacks that
You' usually have to travel to try
people love it and Beyond the snacks
each boxu comes with a booklet that
teaches you all about the theme and
where the snacks come from so that you
can have a deeper appreciation for what
it is you're munching on the first box
of any boxu subscription is the seasons
of Japan after that you receive a new
theme every month with curated seasonal
Stacks one of my favorite things for
these is a white strawberry it's so
sweet and the strawberries infused with
white chocolate to just make like oh my
God it's Heaven it's a bite of heaven
I'm telling you but they also have these
Smoky radish chips which compared with
the the sweet white chocolate strawberry
this just makes for a nice Smoky
something
something oh yeah o so good so good both
I and the new Rockstar's office have
been receiving these boxes for ages we
love them so if you want to try boxu and
support the channel click the link in
the description and use code rockstars
to get $15 off your order but we got to
talk about Agatha's New Look Agatha's
look has been updated so that it's kind
of similar to her appearance when she
resurrects in the final issue of James
Robinson's 2015 Scarlet Witch run when
Wanda lets Agatha Spirit be alive again
and Agatha does what she heads straight
for a nude beach because of course she
does but notice her new brooch in W
division that brooch had the Three
Graces of Greek mythology those Three
Graces were the daughters of Zeus each
bestowing a different gift to humanity
there is eosin who gave mirth Elia who
gave elegance and Talia who gave Youth
and Beauty but now AGA has a new Broach
it's very subtle but it is different
this time and it depicts the three
goddesses archetype of neopaganism the
maiden the mother and the Crone I want
to thank Scarlet Witch updates on
Twitter for sharing like every little
bit of Scarlet Witch news that they
could
I love this account give them a follow
now these triple goddesses have had a
lot of different associations with a lot
of different mythologies but in Greek
mythology they're considered one of the
forms of heati or heate or heti or heate
depending on whatever English teacher
you had in high school or mythology
teacher you had in college it seems like
everyone pronounced it wrong but I'm
pretty sure it's haati anyway haati is a
goddess of Witchcraft and a major figure
in that Robinson 2015 scarly witch run
Wanda finds her on the Greek island of
Santorini and a lot of stuff goes down I
don't want to spoil it just read that
comic run it's incredible and during W
division actually you may remember a lot
of people thought Dy might be heate
turns out not to be the case but Amic
Coffield Ford is returning to the show
so all those theories are back on the
table folks now in this shot we see
Agatha in front of Ralph Bonner's house
you remember that number 2804 I say it's
Ralph boner house because she overtook
it so that she could be right next door
to Wanda you remember that house having
the same blue trim on the window
shutters and this is the same Burbank
Backlot house that was used for the
classic sitcom of Bewitched you'll
notice the mailbox here is overstuffed
and there is one letter sticking out
with some chaotic stamps and ink all
over it then there is a moment when
Agatha shouts something and most folks
seem to think that kathern Han is
screaming these words blast me you
she could be ordering the coven
to hit her with their sorcery the way
evanora harnesses coven did in that 17th
century moment in water Vision episode
8's prologue because that is what gave
her so much power she could be trying to
regain her magic and a later shot Agatha
lets dust run through her hand in this
same location so maybe she drained
another Rich's power and reduced the
them do dust but that would seemed like
a pretty big moment rumor has that this
footage that we see in this promo only
encompasses the first three episodes but
maybe the most interesting shot is this
one glimpse of Aubrey Plaza as rova doll
she is on the right side of the shot
she's hooded she's standing on a higher
platform in a threatening pose over
Agatha who wears a bathrobe on the left
side of frame but if you look at Rio's
right hand she is clutching a dagger and
then to the right of Agatha in that open
closet someone is crouching down low
hiding I'm pretty sure this is Joe lock
who is playing A Team character whom we
are pretty sure is a teenage version of
Billy Kaplan AKA Wiccan meanwhile miles
Gutierrez Riley is rumored to be playing
Billy's boyfriend Teddy AKA Hulan who is
in a relationship with Wiccan and the
Young Avengers Comics we will see Joe
elsewhere in this footage and he seems
to be in a kind of familiar status with
Agatha then we venture out into these
spooky woods which appear to be the
witches Road AKA magika an
interdimensional realm where only
witches and sorceresses can tread which
is also from that Robinson 2015 Scarlet
Witch run in these shots we see Agatha
and Billy l Alice Jennifer kale someone
else in a hat but notice that all of
these characters are Barefoot remember
Scarlet Witch Wanda was also Barefoot
when she slaughtered the Illuminati of
the 838 Universe in Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness so being
Barefoot may be a sacred ritual in which
witches have to be without shoes or any
kind of foot coverings in order to pay
respect when they cross through this
plane I think I am more excited for aga
than I am any other ofcy Marvel Disney
plus series maybe I'm just excited to go
back to that W Vision era when it seemed
like anything was possible and I got to
wake up every Friday morning and just
react to episodes with Jessica Clemens
it was so much fun please subscribe to
all three channels of the new rock stars
Network and you can support us by
grabbing some merch at nerd. shop you
can follow me on all social platforms at
eaos thank you for watching and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
bye
la